aux etats unis c'est un événement le
temple de l'art moderne le moma s'offre
une nouvelle jeunesse à nouveau musée
plus spacieux plus accueillants mieux
éclairé de véritable fenêtre sur new
york pour ce premier musée d'art moderne
au monde qui a été entièrement rénové
pascal golomer new yorkaise où touristes
ils n'auraient manqué l'événement sous
aucun prétexte
un nouveau moment après trois ans de
travaux cela vaut bien quelques heures
d'attentes sous la pluie je voulais
juste être là pour être parmi les
premiers à voir le musée l'ouverture des
portes
enfin et les visiteurs partent à la
découverte du moderne comme on l'appelle
ici un immense atrium ouvert sur la
ville une maison de verre de granit et
de métal tout en transparence qui
s'élève sur cinq étages je pense que les
oeuvres d'art se font très bien avec l'
architecture ce qui n'était pas vraiment
le cas dans l'ancien musée maintenant
c'est comme si demain guinée nuit même
était une oeuvre d'art paraît difficile
pourtant que de rénover et d'agrandir un
musée vieux de 75 ans coincée au milieu
des gratte ciel de manhattan
pari réussi avec ses très grands espaces
ces formes épurées le moma s'est
métamorphosée tout en restant fidèle à
son esprit d'origine 350 millions
d'euros de travaux tout de même mais
l'architecte un japonais n'a pas voulu
épater ni choquer juste bâtir les crains
que merritt est l'une des plus
importantes collections d'art moderne au
monde bâtir un lieu de vie aussi vous
avez des gens de tous les pays
dans un environnement très paisible ils
viennent regarder les tableaux ou
simplement passer un moment ensemble
je suis très heureux d'avoir créé un tel
espace la ville en avait besoin
le musée double sa surface d'exposition
ce qui permet de présenter aux côtés des
stars picasso ou van gogh de nouvelles
oeuvres
même les plus volumineuses dans des
conditions exceptionnelles
les oeuvres sont exposées d'un façon
beaucoup
plus intéressant la lumière est
meilleure les espaçant meilleur et donc
même les oeuvres qui sont très bien
connus
puissance tout à fait différent un musée
rénové qui promettent aussi d'innover
d'être à la pointe de la modernité son
public n'attend pas moins de lui à plus
de 15 euros l'entrée le moma devient
l'un des musées les plus chères au monde
il se doit d'être aussi l'un des plus
prestigieux